all right let's begin with last night's
vice presidential debate between
vice president mike pence and joe
biden's running mate kamala harris
senator from california
expectations were very high for kamala
harris her experience as a prosecutor
and certainly her performances
uh during testimony in the senate have
been
uh parts of have been elements of why
expectations were very high for how she
would do and she did well and i believe
that she
won the debate to the extent that there
was a winner but i do think that she was
not nearly as tough on mike pence as she
was on joe biden during
democratic primary debates i think there
were missed opportunities but i'm going
to say more about that
in a little bit but the big picture here
if we want to
we don't want to miss the forest for the
trees and the big picture is that kamala
harris
did well on everything coronavirus
related
she did okay on economic issues and she
was sort of so
so on some other topics which we will
discuss
but if you ask me what will the impact
of this debate be on the election i
believe that it is
almost zero it's it's not zero but it's
very very close to zero
because with everything going on with
donald trump behind in the polls donald
trump
releasing videos from the white house in
which he really doesn't look good which
we will talk about
nothing happened in this debate that
will change the polling very much and
that's not good for donald trump and
mike pence because
if you believe the polling is even
roughly accurate they need something to
put them back in the lead
and the most likely scenario is that in
the next 72 48 24
in the next five minutes some new
scandal will will pop
up and the vice presidential debate will
be all but forgotten but let's look at a
few moments from it first of all
the fact that there even was plexiglas
installed at the last minute between the
candidates
that's not good for mike pence the the
plexiglas
being needed is a topic
that in and of itself is an indictment
of the trump pence handling of
coronavirus and indeed
they went right into coronavirus it was
the first question
i actually think this was kamala
harris's best moment
of the entire debate coming right at the
beginning well
the american people have witnessed what
is
the greatest failure of any presidential
administration in the history of our
country
and here are the facts two hundred and
ten thousand dead people in our country
in just the last several months over
seven million people who have contracted
this disease
one in five businesses closed
we're looking at frontline workers who
have been treated
like sacrificial workers we are looking
at
over 30 million people
who in the last several months had to
file for unemployment
and here's the thing on january 28th
the vice president and the president
were informed
about the nature of this pandemic they
were informed that it's lethal
in consequence that it is airborne
that it will affect young people and
that
it would be contracted because it is
airborne
and they knew what was happening and
they didn't tell
you can you imagine so this was kamala's
best moment
if you watched only the first question
or
only the first 10 minute segment which
was on coronavirus and then you bailed
on the debate
you would come away with the best
possible impression of how it went for
kamala harris
the rest of the debate was more mixed
because mike pence kept
going over his time sometimes by as much
as a minute the moderator was unable to
get him under control
mike pence would continually avoid
answering the actual question being
discussed by going back and answering
the previous question
or going two questions back at one point
it got so bad i wondered if pence was
going to ask
to spend some time on questions from his
2016 debate with tim kaine he just
wanted to set the agenda himself
and combining that with the kind of calm
arrogant delivery that pence is known
for
i think certainly he came up uh
looking good enough that his base
is not going to say i can no longer
support trump pence because of pence
whether any undecideds were convinced to
the extent that they still remain
uh much less clear here's an example of
pence doing this pence asked why does
the u.s have a much higher death rate
than just about every other country
mike pence just talks about something
else higher
than that of almost every other wealthy
country and you have two minutes to
respond without interruption
susan thank you and i want to thank the
commission and the university of utah
for
hosting this event and senator harris
it's privileged to be on the stage with
you
and our nation has gone through a very
challenging time this year
but i want the american people to know
that from the very
first day president donald trump has put
the health of america first
before there were more than five cases
in the united states
all people who had returned from china
so i'll spare you the torture but he did
about two minutes of that without
actually answering
why does the united states have one of
the highest death
rates per capita in the world from
coronavirus
in another moment mike pence was asked
about that super spreader event that
they held at the white house not this
past saturday but the previous one
the nomination party for amy coney
barrett
and uh of course we know that that event
was at least partially responsible for
multiple
instances multiple cases of coronavirus
related to the white house watch pence
just bail out
let's speak up on behalf of what the
american people have done vice president
pence you were in the front row
in a rose garden event 11 days ago what
seems to have been a super spreader
event for senior administration and
congressional officials
no social distancing few masks and now a
cluster of coronavirus cases among those
who were there
how can you expect americans to follow
the administration's
safety guidelines to protect themselves
from covid
when you at the white house have not
been doing so
well the american people have
demonstrated
over the last eight months that when
given the facts
they're willing to put the health of
their families and their neighbors and
people they don't even know
first and president trump and i have
great confidence in in the american
people and
and their ability to take that
information
and put it into practice in the height
of the epidemic
so that is not pence building to some
kind of clear answer about the super
spreader event at the white house
that's pence ranting and raving about
other things and that was the entire
debate
here's an example of mike pence
apparently realizing that the
coronavirus portion of the debate at the
beginning did not go well for him
here is pence asked about presidential
health and
age and disability and mike pence just
says well i'm going to keep talking
about coronavirus
had a conversation or reached an
agreement
with president trump about safeguards or
procedures when it comes to the issue
of presidential disability and if not do
you think you should you have two
minutes without interruption
well susan uh thank you although i would
like to go back
i think we need to move on well thank
you but i would like to go back
because the reality is that we're going
to have a vaccine
senator in record time that was the
whole debate i won't give you more
examples of that
mike pence also did some of his normal
theatrics which include
refusing to accept the science on
climate change
repeating donald trump's talking point
about how
forest fires could be solved by forest
management
which they claim democrats are either
against or aren't doing
and then maybe the most bizarre moment
of the debate was when a fly
landed on mike pence's head and stayed
there for minutes and
the the fly landing on mike pence's head
was funny to start with but the fact
that it seemed to be stuck in mike
pence's hair gel
was even funnier and uh that instantly
became a viral moment
the joe biden campaign immediately
starting to sell fly swatters
and you know many many uh allegories
made
to the biblical meaning of when a fly
lands
lands on you for those more religious
folks in the audience it's it's ominous
it's not good
uh but the moment that many say was
kamala harris's
worst of the debate was when the topic
of packing the courts came up now
the question came up during the biden
trump debate last week and the question
is if joe biden is elected
and republicans confirm amy coney
barrett to the supreme court will joe
biden pack the supreme court meaning
add seats to the supreme court and
kamala harris much like joe biden did
not give a yes or no answer and there's
a lot of people who are saying it looks
really bad
for kamala not to answer the question
i'm not so
sure let me explain there clearly has
been a strategic decision made
by the biden campaign not to answer yes
or no about whether joe biden would pack
the court
i don't think court packing is a voting
issue
for many people so really there's a lot
of potential downside to giving a
straight answer and i'll explain what i
mean
if they say yes or no they number one
make the answer the focus rather than
the threat
of using this in the future and if you
answer yes or no
the unknown threat of maybe biden will
pack the court
goes away and so i understand the risk
when you decide you're not going to
answer a question there's a risk that
you're going to appear evasive
but i understand the strategy because i
don't think there's much to gain by
saying definitively yes
or no if biden and harris say yes if amy
coney barrett gets confirmed
we will pack the court the right and
those on the left who don't want the
court pact
will go crazy and that becomes the focus
rather than republican hypocrisy
about confirming amy coney barrett with
just days left before an election
if biden harris say we won't pack the
court
they bail out the gop and they're
basically saying
even if you confirm amy coney barrett
don't worry we're not going to pack the
court so while i
accept that harris didn't answer i
actually
understand why and it will be a question
as to whether it works or doesn't work
but that but i i get the strategy mike
pence also during the debate
seemed to have a fat lip and his left
eye was either bloody with a burst blood
vessel
or with pink eye which can sometimes
happen with coronavirus so it was
impossible not to notice his physical
appearance during the debate
it was bizarre but big picture the
debate
was not a nothing burger i think that
you saw
how you know when kamala harris went
after joe biden in the primary
you imagined there would be more
ferocity and energy from her against
mike pence
and i took live calls last night after
the debate and a bunch of my callers
said you know sometimes when women
are assertive or aggressive in popular
culture
it counts against them the martha
stewart effect as it's sometimes been
described
and i think that that is absolutely true
to a degree
i still would have liked to see a
balanced approach that had kamala harris
more on the offensive which we know she
can do we've seen her do it in the
senate
we've seen her do it in other contexts
but the big picture is i don't think the
debate is going to change a thing and
when the polling is looking so bad for
trump and pence
with now only 25 days left until this
election
they need something to turn it around
and this debate is not going to be the
thing that does it
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called teddy stratford i love
these shirts and that's why i asked them
to be a sponsor of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button-up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because all of their shirts come
with a patented
zipper hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but most
importantly just overall it makes the
shirt fit
much better and look better the
carefully designed
shirt is also cut in a way that improves
the look of your upper body physique it
has a really nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you
it also has a specially designed collar
that won't
fall down and lay flat which i love the
difference all around with these shirts
really is noticeable go check them out
at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout